how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk
all things marvel and of course
spider-man no
way home the spider-verse film that has
yet to be confirmed to be a spider-man
film by
marvel studios and sony but has pretty
much been confirmed by everybody else
including some of the actors that are
going to be
in the movie and there has just been so
many leaks and
rumors and reports and instagram posts
of stunt doubles tagging other stunt
doubles and there's just been so much
going on i'm going to break down
every important thing that we've heard
about spider-man no way home so far
and thank you to squarespace for
sponsoring this video more on them in a
bit
and reminder about my stormbreaker
giveaway it ends at the end of this
month so be sure to check out the
description and pin comment for details
on how to enter
so in this video we're going to go over
14 different things that you
need to know about the upcoming
spider-man no way home film
each of these points are very important
topics that have come out about the
movie over the past year or so my buddy
chris over at cosmic culture originally
did a video on this
shout out to him he's done a great job
let's dive into it number one
the president of marvel studios kevin
feige said himself
that this film no way home is going to
connect to doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness it's going to lead
up to it with that came the confirmation
that benedict cumberbatch's doctor
strange will indeed be in spiderman no
way home
now why is he in spiderman no way home
there are a lot of other heroes that
could help peter out that are in new
york and the answer is
doctor strange knows how to deal with
the multiverse
so right away the multiverse being in
spiderman away home is a
pretty big sign that the spiderverse is
also going to be in no way home
point number two and this is kind of
like the biggest deal to me because it's
a personal experience and that is i got
copy striked
not copyright claimed copy striked it's
a big deal
by the latin america sony group and the
video that they copy striked was their
promotional video for the spiderverse
if you didn't get a chance to see this
video it's a video that sony latin
america put out that talked about
seeing all three spider verses in one
film it started off by asking who your
favorite spider-man was and then it went
on to say that all three of them are
going to appear in the same film
and they were specifically talking about
spider-man no way home they talked about
seeing the movie on christmas
of 2021 the release date for no way home
now obviously this video was not
supposed to go out it was quickly
removed after but i posted it
and they took it down and when
spider-man far from home came out they
released multiple trailers and multiple
tv spots in which i posted them all
doing breakdowns and showing clips they
never claimed a single one of them
so why would they claim this video well
it's probably because it revealed the
spider-verse and that is something they
do not want shown
so to me that's really the big one a lot
of proof to me the third point is the
recent andrew garfield interviews
you know the ones where he claims that
he's not the werewolf or he's not the
mafia
to be frank i think it's a really cool
idea in these interviews he
kind of denies that he's going to be in
no way home but he never
actually says he's not in the film he
talks about the game werewolf and mafia
where the whole point is to convince
people that you're not the werewolf and
you're not the mafia he states he feels
like he's playing the game
and he's telling everybody hey i'm not
the werewolf but the whole point
if you're the werewolf is to convince
people you're not the werewolf so
he's literally saying i'm not the
werewolf meaning i'm not in the film but
again the point of the werewolf is to
convince people you are not the werewolf
so it really seems like he's
in the movie and he's just trying to
convince people that he's not in the
movie he also had this pretty well
rehearsed story about the werewolf and
the mafia that he seemed to tell in each
interview
but then out of nowhere in another
interview he said
never say never he dropped the whole
story and when he was asked about ever
appearing with the other two spider-man
he said never say never
so i already didn't believe him in the
first two interviews but then he turned
around and completely changed the story
so
i really don't believe him now then we
have point number four going over
to another spider-man toby maguire right
when the filming for spider-man no way
home was starting the paparazzi snagged
a lot of pictures of toby maguire going
to a costume fitting
and here's the deal toby maguire doesn't
have any upcoming movies he was
rumored to be playing a character in
babylon but that has yet to be confirmed
so
really the only movie that he could be
getting fitted for
is spider-man no way home now he was
spotted before filming and then he was
spotted after filming and after
filming he looked a lot better than he
did before he was clean-shaven
and he was in better shape and this is
most likely due to him playing his old
role of peter parker now obviously he
doesn't do
all of the stunts but he doesn't just
sit there and do nothing so that would
explain why he is all of a sudden in
much better shape
and since we're talking about actors for
no way home that brings me to my fifth
point which
is alfred molina this dude basically
confirmed the spider-verse i mean
he actually did confirm it in the
interview he talked about how he asked
director john watts how his character is
going to all of a sudden be alive when
the last time we saw him he was dead
in which he told us that the director
said in this universe
nobody really dies and he also revealed
that they're going to take his
character from that very final moment
right before he dies and that's where
we're going to pick off with the
character
so right at this moment he's going to be
taken away from the sam
raymond universe right before he dies
and brought into the marvel cinematic
universe from one spider-man universe to
another
if that is not confirming the
spider-verse i don't really know what
else is
except for you know marvel coming out
and stating that hey it's the
spider-verse hopefully that happens soon
but in the meantime let's continue on
with point number six
sticking with actor confirmations point
number six is jamie foxx
jamie foxx will be returning in no way
home as elektra which he played in the
amazing spider-man universe
after one of the trade companies
reported that jamie foxx would be
returning as elektro in no way home
jamie foxx posted on his instagram also
confirming that he is indeed coming
however he did delete the post not too
long after that but that's always a good
sign for us they only really delete
things because
marvel studios tells them hey you
weren't supposed to put that take that
off ah
it's usually a pretty good sign point
number seven is
jj j jonah jameson of the daily bugle
all of a sudden he is back and he's in
the mcu and of course he is still
being played by jk simmons i get
bringing jjj
into the mcu because we haven't seen him
yet but why use the same actor
why use the actor from the raimi
universe if some type of spider-verse
wasn't involved
so he's back and now we have
confirmation that alfred molina who is
from the same universe the rhema
universe
is coming back as well and a ton of
reports stating that willem defoe's
green goblin is coming back too
so really that's just another
confirmation that this movie is going to
be a spider-verse film
and we're only halfway through all of
the points but before we get to point
number eight big thank you to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
if you own a business if you have a
youtube channel if you're a blogger if
you're just trying to build a
social online presence squarespace is
for you
squarespace is the leader in website
design the reason they're the leaders is
because they make building a website
super simple
they offer custom templates and give you
a ton of tools and analytics to help you
run your
site they can do everything from putting
embedded videos on your website
opening up an online store or connecting
your social media accounts to drive
traffic there as well
and for people like me who haven't spent
multiple years and a lot of money
learning how to code
squarespace is perfect because they
offer exactly what i want and it's super
simple to use
head over to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com
the cosmic wonder to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or domain
point number eight the trailers for
morbius and
venom let there be carnage now i think
everybody was pretty shocked to see the
picture of spider-man on the wall
in the morbius trailer over the picture
it said murderer
implying that this could be tom holland
spider-man and the reason they're saying
murderer is because of what mysterio has
framed him for
so people probably think that spider-man
murdered mysterio
however the picture on the wall is of
the sam
raimi spider-man costume this further
points to a connection of
a spider-verse happening then in the
venom 2
trailer we see stephen graham's
character reading a newspaper that is
the daily bugle with the
exact same logo that the daily bugle had
in the sam
raimi tobey mcguire films so this daily
bugle which
is apparently the same one already
exists in another
universe and before people get started
talking about how this venom universe
could be the sam raimi universe
it's not we already had an eddie brock
and venom in that universe they are
clearly different
but this daily bugle is the same which
means there is some multiverse stuff
happening here
point number eight tom holland that poor
kid
he spoiled a lot for far from home and
other things as well and he's trying so
hard not to spoil anything for this
upcoming movie
unfortunately he's kind of all over the
place right now
one second when he's being asked about
the spider-verse he's telling us that he
doesn't know anything
then in another interview when he's not
specifically asked about the
spider-verse he says
i know everything about the film so
clearly he is trying to avoid talking
about the spider-verse so he doesn't
accidentally spoil the fact that it is
happening in no way home point number 10
is that sony and disney have recently
reached a new deal with each other
the sony spider-man films are finally
going to be on disney plus and when new
ones come out they will be on disney
plus as well
now what this shows us is that sony and
disney are playing
nice we were scared that before when
they were doing that renegotiation that
spider-man tom hall and spider-man might
not stay in the mcu
but unfortunately over a year ago they
came to a new agreement and it looks
like now they're still playing really
nice with each other
this means that both parties must think
that spider-man no way home is going to
be an
insanely good film and if the
spider-verse is involved of course it is
there's really no way it could fail
even if it's not as good as homecoming
or far from home the fact that it has
the spider verse in it is going to make
it one of the biggest movies of all time
and with reports stating that andrew and
toby might not actually be done
after this movie it would make sense
that sony and disney would want to
extend their agreement and contracts
point number
11 stunt doubles tagging each other on
instagram
we have had many reportings of andrew
garfield's stunt double being spotted on
the set of no way home while posting a
video
one day that was seemingly on the set of
no way home he actually tagged
toby maguire stunt double in another
post he tagged tom holland stunt double
now there's really only one reason why
all three
of the spider-man stunt doubles would be
together and that is of course to film
for their respective spider-man
and this one offers a lot of validation
for the fact that there are going to be
three spider-man
in the film point number 12 one of the
crew members of no way home posting a
picture of some
merch that they got for the film one
included a shirt that had andrew
garfield spider-man on it with other
parts that were hidden
probably hiding other spider-man so we
have a spider-man
no way home shirt with andrew garfield
spider-man
on it well there's really only one
explanation for that andrew garfield
spider-man is in the movie
now of course this was later removed and
i'm not too sure how accurate this is
but i heard
rumblings that that crew member could
have gotten fired who knows that
is a pretty big leak then we have number
13 which i briefly talked about before
we have willem dafoe's green goblin
talked about
in just a ton of different reports and
leaks
based off of everything we know right
now willem the foes green goblin from
the sam raimi universe
is going to be the main villain i mean
why not alfred molina's
doc akka is coming in jamie foxx's
elektra was coming and we have a bunch
of other villains reportedly coming as
well so if we have
two people alfred and molina and willem
dafoe coming from the sam raimi universe
it would make sense that toby maguire
spider-man comes
and lastly for point number 14 is the
overall direction that everything is
heading towards
literally almost everything that we know
if not
everything that we know about spider-man
no way home points to it being a
multiverse
spider-verse film i mean even the title
no way home could be about
no way back to his original universe now
of course we think it's going to be
because he's going to be on the run as a
fugitive
after being framed for the murder of
mysterio but it could be about either
him or
other characters not being able to get
back home every league that we've had
every major report from a major trade
company has
all said that this is going to be a
spider-verse
film at this point if it's not a
spider-verse film and
all of these things are wrong i'm going
to be in absolute shock
and i think that everybody else is going
to be as well but let me know what you
think is this enough evidence to
basically confirm the spider-verse in no
way home or do you think that all of
this is either simply coincidence or
intentional misdirect from marvel
studios let me know what you think down
below don't forget to subscribe to stay
up to date on all of the latest
spider-man and
mcu news don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching
[Music]